[Music]
in a graffiti grainy news oh I'm sure
that's tight when grandma's do like cool
contemporary like youthful [ __ ] I always
give them props no matter how illegal
like if I was like yo I'm taking up
drive-by shootings I'll be like tiger ha
ha and as you just see you're like
[ __ ] in the backseat like respect I'm
like BAM grandma drop you're living it
up submitted by a Jamaa lien a singles
whoo got a new website making any
website open I saw the sudden name in
Crimea correctly you get more more
creative with the drawings awesome guys
I love it I don't have to do any work or
create it your creativity which is also
about a 72 year old dubbed the hate
destroyer has been cleaning up the
streets of Germany for 31 years
oh she's just coming by graffiti and
doing it white like or whatever the
Wallace she gets the color of the wall
sighs only that page she doing the
opposite of what you like what does she
do it she's cleaning up the food grandma
yeah the thug grandma's coming at art
and she's the grandmother comes it
cleans it up
is that what's happenin yep damn
grandmas was she so she's just community
service grandma ah that's cool she's my
board a [ __ ]
yeah this is our Mela 70 years old she
looks like a [ __ ] grandma like like
an image of a girl right that is so
disappointing
I brought up a grandma was a [ __ ] like
a do-rag yeah yeah yeah I don't the
longer lightweight like she next to a
dirty water she there you can watch the
car right next to her I think she's
trying to cross out the swastika yeah
below don't you just see the whole thing
white why because there's already a lot
of other graffiti on it she could
totally just erased it is what she does
she does what he's [ __ ] funny
she'll spray-paint hearts over any like
hate graffiti or anything that's
associated with like not Jesus oh she's
just she's anti skinhead that's all I
ask
but you still drifting crying Honda yeah
yeah is she scared and get tackled by
police officers
what if she's doing the heart and the
police officer think that she was one to
the swatter and it tackle doesn't beat
her ass yeah well you could see it like
the her other cover up here's another
heart a butterfly she's got multiple
colors yeah she has a whole bag with her
that she carries and then she has a
scraper kind of stuff so much remover so
she could remove stickers that have I
can't like you don't suck at a heart
yeah I know she got away
you know what's really funny though this
is the rival of the skinheads haha this
little last lady like I imagine like oh
the white supremacist gang and then the
black gang but it's actually them aunt
grandma yeah she showed her face now was
she gonna do know what she's had like
death threats really doing this for your
head from 34 31 years you should be
ashamed of yourself into 72 yeah why
would they want to kill grandma let's
talk about skinhead like they got morals
and change yeah they got no morals but
she's still someone's grandma I feel
like at the skinhead meeting like if
someone wasn't no [ __ ] up there's got
to be one person that's like I don't
know like you know like we beat up a
side of black I know about the grandma
you know and there must be that I want a
person with a heart so I'm gonna show
you guys a little clip of an interview
she did with CNN skinheads in Germany
that's gay I said where I thought was
American that's where the skin is k-pro
I thought that was an American thing
copying Nazi I thought it was making two
Americans copying Nazis or whatever but
then they also caught it it could have
been neo-nazis copying Nazis and then
got neo neo Nazis covering the noise
that nunu they're always copied each
other back or yeah that's what happened
because my cousin he lived in Spain for
a minute and then he had his uh friends
from the US of A come visit him and they
went to a bar it was one age' one
Mexican in a black and after the bar
something the beginning of the knock
knock she said that there was like 20
really skinny like skinhead guys with
swastika tattoos that came up and wanted
to fight all of them would it would it
are you do you what can we do we can't
fight with 20 of these guys and there's
just like well uh and they just left
yeah yeah which was not under the
scraper kind of spray paint and nail
polish remover [ __ ] doctor fast then she
sees it another horrible why they go
street graffiti she gets to work they
don't even didn't even have straight
edges look at that a political cleaner
of neo Nazi and racist graffiti trumps
everything
seventeen hours scraping off racist
stickers and painting over swastikas
four fingertips metallic shiny satin but
you gotten cinematic oh I could look at
that swastika and say oh that's awful
and walk by she says but no one would
dare to do anything well I don't want to
wait for someone else to do something
about it she knows at home doesn't had a
lot of work it started 30 years ago when
she spotted a flyer supporting convicted
Nazi war criminal Rudolf Hess plastered
to her bus stop disgusted she took her
house keys and scratched the flyer off
when an average Spanish horse could
survived and I just scrub the hate away
until it was all gone she said it was a
fantastic feeling afterwards the mind
pollution was gone she was probably
still alive during that time too
involved in Austria in Poland it has
become a personal mission that has taken
her generation born in Georgia yes she
has cleaned and the amount she sees on
the street things in our Arsenal the
heart the butterfly knives actions
against refugees people tell me I am
intolerant that I don't respect the far
rights freedom of speech she says but I
say freedom of speech
limit it ends where hatred and contempt
for Humanity begins he has entered death
threats police have warned that her work
is too provocative and that she could
face thousands of dollars in fines for
defacing public property that's crazy
they wonder they're going to find her
mm-hmm who's going to find her the skin
grunts they write they write tickets now
yeah my Widow bad grandma chug
she's known as destroyer that's so funny
though she's my grandma Polly join her
for like lunch and then go like hearts
and butterflies and [ __ ] yeah I'm
surprised she doesn't have a crew now
yeah do you think sounds pretty fun but
you're right what why are they
threatening her because ruining their
efforts but they could go back and do it
that means like it's not like but it's
wasting their time you have a schedule
duh you know how hard I worked on that
dude you're busted by all thanks
Alliance they don't host
don't they have strategy so they go from
one city to another so you'd have a tour
schedule and now they got to go back at
the agent yeah they're messing up the
entire tour why don't they just be like
regular graffiti artist and just keep
battling back and forth I mean that's
how they do it you get crossed out you
just paint again and you just keep going
how I wish until I come in here on ray
they're so petty dude you know what the
neo-nazis out there actually really
sensitive cuz they're like hey grandma I
don't like it that you're blocking or
Spri speech you're [ __ ] me that's
what it sounds like
just battle her out man be like be a
real graffiti artist cross her out put a
[ __ ] swastika over her heart back and
forth who's the king of the city no one
has more time than the grandma true oh
yeah we tried it ready I know she's
retired I could be right I think I'm
right on this route it might be seven
hours a week or is it either way it's a
lot yeah that's a lot well you can't
beat an old person that's retired
patience she's mastered [ __ ] patience
yeah she's [ __ ] mastered she'll sit
there and scrub her life away yeah
because she does that there will be
people you know yelling at her or even
the Pope the city or the cleaning crew
themselves we'll go up to her and be
really upset with her because it's like
you know we're I love what you're doing
you're not doing it the right way that's
what the city
and and then she just lasted what are
they talk to me that's kind of to be
expected though like your expect them to
say that what do they do they're not
doing it fast enough Lee because in this
interview this is just like a shorter
version of the interview but the longer
version you can see that the city people
actually approach her and say the cave
like what I just said like you're we
like what you're doing you're just not
doing it the right way and so she'll
laugh it off she turns around and she
sees something else across the street
and she closes one of them she has she's
loose yeah
Shane's got [ __ ] to do I know you like
what I'm going to put me in jail for
twenty years I live that long I don't
know when you guys get older you feel
like you might end up doing things like
this where is if you don't give a [ __ ]
about the consequences anymore I've
never been at Ted I don't think of that
type of either and we just shown the
[ __ ] out okay it depends you know
because for her it seems like she might
have lived through she's old enough yeah
from that era or it's still fresh in her
mind when Hitler destroyed her country
because she's German right so she
probably doesn't want anything like that
happen again so it's a lot more personal
that means for us we would be the old
geezers going on line and talking back
to the troll it [ __ ] troll out I
would be down anti trolling that's our
generation I won't do that it is true
though maybe we're just not as attached
to something yeah we probably don't do a
book because if I see is so classic I
just go oh Buddhism you know peace and
prosperity that's great guys hey what's
up guys thanks for watching we are going
to regularly start posting content on
the JK films Instagram so make sure you
follow us there a lot videos click over
here
[Music]